vraiment aujourd'hui une colère face à
la réponse à l'ebbo la jouanne lit ou
connaît bien les congolais de l'est du
pays où elle a fait de nombreuses
missions souvent sous les bombardements
elle comprend leur colère depuis vingt
ans les combats et les maladies ont fait
des millions de morts dans
l'indifférence
beaucoup de gens se demandent pourquoi
la terre entière atterri chez eux
vous n'y répondra les bonnes a vu que
pendant les deux dernières décennies
sont morts au combat souhaite aider
les blessures de guerre suite à des
épidémies de rougeole de diarrhée
liquide et pourquoi les mollahs
ça fait partie d'un choeur soucis mais
un parmi tant d'autres la pédiatre était
encore au nord kivu le mois dernier
juste après l'attaqué contre un centre
de traitement ebola 85 employés de ces
centres ont été tués ou blessés depuis
janvier dans une quarantaine d' attaque
cas qu'on est dans un pays où un conflit
le système de santé est en déliquescence
qu'est ce qui se passe que les gens ne
comprennent pas que je ne suis plus
intéressant quand je n'ai pas les mots
là après l'épidémie d'ebola qui avait
fait 11 morts en afrique de l'ouest il y
a cinq ans
l'occident a eu peur d'être contaminés
et a mis le paquet pour mieux réagir la
prochaine fois maintenant on a le vaccin
sans mais le congolais ont été vaccinés
et un traitement mais plus de 60 % des
malades en meurt quand même parce qu'ils
refusent de se faire soigner
et comme beaucoup s'éteignent chez eux
entourés des leurs la propagation
s'accélère une méfiance voire une
défiance
oui surtout les acteurs de la réponse
aujourd'hui
et moi je constate qu'on est juste à
s'en prendre à nous mêmes
de toute évidence on n'a pas trouvé la
bonne recette joigny ajoute qu ici on ne
donne qu'une réponse technique ça ne
marche pas et pourtant cette fois ci la
riposte a été rapide et massive mais on
a oublié le facteur humain la méfiance
accumulée contre toute autorité et la
colère de populations appauvries qui
voit l'onu et les ong débarqué pour
soigner les boules à seulement on arrive
beaucoup moyens beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup d'étrangers avec des retombées
localement pour des gens qui sont
moindres que pour les trajets si l'on
veut soigner une population déjà
profondément meurtri il faut d'abord ces
reconnaissances se parlent et se faire
accepter
donc quand les gens viennent on prend
soin d'eux parce que et on les bat là
aussi on prend soin d'eux parce qu'ils
ont le mot ni parce que de malaria est
ce qu'on dirait lesquels le mandat de la
montréalaise à la tête de msf prendra
fin cet été
si elle fait une dernière mission d'ici
là ce sera probablement pour retourner
en république démocratique du congo ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal